thanks guys we are indeed with the
co-leader right now going into day three
Wesley Wesley a good day at the office
plus one but it could have been even
better especially because of this last
game between the leaders yourself and
Duda you had some chances take us
through the game yeah for sure I think I
had very good chances
um
but
you know at the same time I go into
every game hoping to play my best but I
don't know whether I'll get any chances
to win or not so this one surprisingly I
did have but my first uh when you came
in the studio you asked me if you played
a good game and you did play a good game
so yeah that's my entire
in this tournament that should be
everyone's goal I guess if you're a
player let's just try to play well and
uh try to play some good moves because
even if you play your best sometimes you
don't always win or you don't get
chances especially in Rapid and Blitz
when you know the variance is very high
yeah for sure so I think I I should have
won this game but at the same time I won
two games yesterday that maybe shouldn't
have ended in victories so it is what it
is but of course it's a Pity but I
blunder this King G1 we need to in the
end let's take a look at it but first he
played the petroff which he always plays
his very sold opening so he played this
in Romania as well yeah so you were
expecting him to start with the petrol
yeah for sure I mean he there are many
lines in the petrol but he always goes
for this bishop F5 Bishop E7 I think
younger stuff also plays the Sicilian
and some Knight C6 on the second move
but better off is a very solid opening
oh
not babe
I played the B3 first
um ah yeah this so this this game is
wrong
it might be because there were some
people I played
the wrong button just a second oh sorry
my bad
exit in just a second there we go back
to your game still getting used to the
leeches
but yes finally enough
uh you can right now finally if I if you
remember I played this a few months ago
against our friend Hans Neiman so I
played 96 as black and he played this
new idea Bishop E5 and then I played
this exact same position against any
house iron in the finals of the global
Chess Championship
so I was white against antimon that was
black so I played it quite a few times
also playing some practice Blitz Games
but my game against nihal wasn't input
into the database for some reason yeah
so yeah finding good moves but yeah I
thought H4 was correct it means why they
slightly better definitely from a
practical perspective it did feel like
you were piling on pressure right now
yeah I was really surprised when he
played H5 because I thought Knight G5
and I guess G6 was a mistake you should
play 94 I guess G6 G4 because there's so
so many pieces
around black for example this
very typical break and your king is
actually safe even with the opening of
the G file yeah yeah thanks to the you
know if you have three minor pieces
that's pretty nice close to the enemy
King yeah like only a bishop
let's keep it going okay 96 was
something funnily enough I was
calculating Knight D5 but it doesn't
mean in fact
black is better
like I thought
white gets three pawns for the piece G
that is nothing yeah
it takes probably just a draw at that
point no I think you made the right
decision right now yeah transition into
this uh sort of middle game yeah but
it's still very Fortune
like
I didn't
calculating this but
anyway it's winning after H4 V1 D1 yeah
I miss queen F4
very nice yeah yeah some uh it's a nice
computer maneuver yeah four yeah so
apparently this is much easier I mean
feed
yeah apparently there's some Queen G4
trick which neither of us well yeah yeah
I guess white is better here but I
couldn't find a way exactly how to
you found the best way
um was a mistake yes but actually only
losing a little bit of the advantage
you're you're still
however I allowed this Knight to move
I had to be very careful with my king
yeah right now this page two and this
was the critical moment when he played
27. sure the position is still difficult
for him but one two E7 pretty much with
a blender yes right away but
it kind of rushed I should just play
Queen C4 yeah Queen C4 and then I guess
A4 Knight takes Queen D3
seven yeah I was gonna play ee4
yeah I guess if
totally winning but I just wondered if
we need to then suddenly it's a draw
yeah queen king G1 was just a terrible
blunder yes I was calculating Queen E5
and thought check I also got including
h420 just didn't see when there's so
many options on the board sometimes you
miss one of them yeah yeah I I win
before Queen E5 Knight H4 been before
Queen C4 just forgot about this was one
square yeah but actually it's funny like
it felt like almost your game against
Richie maybe he will try some uh
for more yeah with Queen to E4 yeah I I
thought the
I thought
yeah it's almost it almost wins for
white
so it's very
yeah fun enough with upon these seven
it's almost winning for white yeah yeah
but he found 93 and this is almost
almost yeah he fortunately got Queen E7
oh but apparently 24th also on the wrong
although I don't know why
uh you got Queen F4
okay but this is some crazy like yeah
Queen F5 yeah so it almost went forward
yeah but uh yeah King G1 was just uh
but okay maybe
um he shouldn't have
yeah he could have defended much better
well Wesley how would you assess your uh
form after the first couple of days
because the result is very good so far
co-leading the event but how do you feel
yourself last year of course yeah yeah
he did really well I think he ended up
on 14 points well again I'm very pleased
to play in Poland very pleased that
Poland is part of the grandchester so
I'm very grateful to be for that and
also to be part of the grand Chancellor
this year I think I could have
played I could have scored Half Point
more in Romania
um and uh yeah here good start so far
but there's still three more days and uh
just uh
take it one day at a time I feel like my
main weakness is I need more opening
ideas like especially my wife openings
need a bit more teeth
but overall I feel that I'm seeing well
that's good I'm seeing like I'm making
mistakes but I'm seeing most of the
ideas that's good that's good Wesley
um very good uh good good game so far
yes one congratulations going into the
final day of Rapid uh co-leading the
event we'll see you tomorrow go get some
rest thank you so much yeah guys thank
you Christian thank you Wesley